what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today
i don't have coffee um i actually have
water
um
not because i quit coffee i actually
relapsed um i know i always say i'm
gonna quit
and okay i always do quit for a couple
weeks and then relapse but to be fair it
took me a long time a lot of tries to
quit drinking
and i think one day i'll actually get it
but that day isn't today i might do a
block of cheese though
i've had better ideas
i don't know why i thought that was a
good idea okay
anyways today
i'm going to talk to you about nuggets
of wisdom that my dad has given me over
the years
that has
helped me
in life
and i don't know it might help you too
my dad
is the wisest man i know
the smartest man i know and the coolest
man i know
so
i'll start
first thing
my dad
said
that he always would focus on himself
and not compare to people because
comparison is a thief of joy
and sometimes i would hear things and it
would put me a damper in my day
like for example
i'd be like dad i'm getting old and
first you'll be like
you're 25.
but i'm like dad
i'm gonna hit my wall or whatever
whatever
and i'm gonna hit my wall and my dad
would be like well
you're just comparing yourself
and like he's like there's nothing you
can do to change it
so
he would always tell me like stop
comparing yourself
or people call me ugly on the internet
i'm looking at you guys
i saw your comments i see them okay
and i'm like dad the internet says i'm
ugly
and i'm like it's your you guys's fault
you guys gave me the jeans
and he would say well you're just
comparing yourself to other people
so there's nothing you can do about it
so you just accept it like you can't so
it's kind of like stop comparing and
stop worrying about things you can't
change because there's literally nothing
you can do to change that
and i was like okay
that's a good idea the second third
thing would be
it's been hard starting this channel
i've lost a lot of friends
that i've
some friends that i was friends for a
very long time
and it put a damper in my day i won't
lie to you it's hard
to lose with friends and
i would say dad
i lost a friend
and he was like first of all he would be
like well how long were you really
friends with them and how how long do
you have to deal with them
and
i would think about it like one girl i'd
known a couple months and we were pretty
close and then he's like well most
people you don't deal with for that long
in life
and so the only relationships you really
need to worry about are your family
your your boyfriend
and
close friends but most people aren't
around for that long
and i was like hmm
and then another thing would happen
where the girls on my team
would just be
chat and [ __ ] like honestly i feel like
i should be paid for giving them
something to talk about
genuinely i feel like i should get money
for being entertaining enough to be
talked about but anyways you know they'd
be like oh did you see what you said in
her show or her story blah blah blah and
i'd be like dad i keep hearing about all
these people talking about me and he's
like who cares like their opinion
changes nothing
and so in life i really don't go out of
my way to find out what people said and
i always assume like people
and this is more of a woman thing but
men or women are going to vent about you
a little bit
and just not to take it personal because
i know i've vented to friends and i
probably said things
that
are a bit hurtful you know about other
people just as they've done to me that
are close and that i love but it's part
of like life
but
what i have found is that if it does
make it back to me like there's a
certain amount of talking [ __ ] i just
don't i try not to find out about
but if it does make it back to me i know
that like
that's a reflection on
our friendship and like their character
because you have to be talking a lot of
[ __ ] for it to make it back to someone
because in life i've always noticed that
most people when they talk [ __ ] like it
doesn't make it back to the person
unless they're doing it a lot i don't
know if that makes sense
i know i'm a little bit of scatter brain
so
my point is this my dad always said
people's opinions doesn't matter
and i would say like dad someone said
this someone said that and he'd be like
who cares
and i was like yeah who does care
because what does it change their
opinion doesn't change anything
your day-to-day life like
you're gonna do the same thing you the
same things are gonna make you happy so
i was like you're right dad
it doesn't change anything
and
you know
if someone has a genuine complaint about
you which is fair
they can bring it to you
anyways um
those are the things that my dad has
taught me growing up i feel like there's
one more that i'm forgetting
oh my last
nugget of gold that my dad told me he
would always say
do what you love
i don't care if it's selling toothpicks
on the side of the road but do what you
love and do it while you're young you're
going to be working for a long time
and make sure it's something you love
because then you'll be good at it
because you're going to put in more
hours if you're doing something you're
actually interested in and that you love
and he always encouraged me to like quit
my job or take the risk because
it like he would have an abundance
mindset where he's like you can always
make more money you can always get oh
sorry my battery slow you can always
make more money you can always get a new
job but just take the risk and do what
you love and when i quit my job and
moved home and said i'm gonna be a
tick-tocker i mean now it's youtube but
it was you know tick tock but
um he he did think i was nuts he was
like you know you couldn't love
something else
so you know dad this is what i like
doing
and
my dad always encouraged me to take
risks while you're young because he said
like life changes
and you won't be able to take the risk
forever because then you're gonna have
to think about other people while you're
young just take the risk you never know
and
the oh and the last thing see my i'm
thinking of all my dad's nuggets he has
so many nuggets he would tell me
i get really stressed out sometimes
about my business
because guys you don't even understand
this stuff blew up so fast
and sometimes i just want to cry
and i'll be on the phone with my dad and
my brothers they're so nice they always
help me with stuff like the budgets and
like expenses and all the stuff that
goes with the business
and making decisions even with like
personnel to ask my dad like
when i should keep people when i should
change people or whatever and
when i get stressed out and i say i want
to cry my dad's like why are you crying
i'm like dad i'm just stressed out and
he's like
hannah because if you didn't know my
first name's hannah my middle name is
pearl and he's like hannah
um
you have your health
that's the most important thing
there's nothing to ever be stressed
about as long as you have your health
and my dad i actually had a scare um
like a year or two ago i gave my dad
covet
um
i went you know it's crazy i gave my dad
covered because i went to go vote i was
on a road trip
and you think i would get it on the road
trip no
nayski where i got it from was
it was election time and i was like i
should i should go vote so i drove all
the way from like south carolina to
freaking
what do you call it um
chica wisconsin
because that's where i lived
and
i stayed with my friend and my friend
was a nurse and my friend had a coconut
so you would think i literally got it to
go vote that's like why i got copied and
then so i gave it to my dad and my dad
um he's like a workaholic so instead of
resting he just like kept working in our
backyard on like projects when he had
coped and
um he didn't actually get sick from
covid he like didn't drink enough water
um so then he's dehydrated and then then
he drank too much water and it was like
low sodium or something i don't know
but he had
a health scare